Gregg Cody Miami Herald columnist and
he's all in for the Dolphins tanking I'm
wondering if the fans tank to Greg and
just don't show up this year and say you
know what let's see how this works out
we'll see you next year
well you know they had a full house for
the opener but a lot of that's just
because it's the opener and it's
curiosity factor and all that I'm sure
that they're gonna see a bunch in those
shows as the season wears on and and I
use the phrase wears on literally be a
long one oh yeah I would imagine that
they're going to see a lot of receipts
who's making this decision to tank I
think it starts from the top with with
Stephen Ross the owner you know he you
know he's been with the club now 10 10
years or so and it's been the same wheel
spinning for 20 years you know ever
since post Moreno really it's just been
a series of non-stop mediocrity
mid-round draft picks and and wheel
spinning and I think finally Ross came
to the realization that this business
model is not working we have to really
break it down and and start from the
ground floor up and and that's what
they've done and you know they've
accrued they have four first-round draft
picks in the next two drafts they have
eight picks in the first two rounds in
the next two drafts so they're pretty
well positioned to to get a franchise
quarterback and and to really go from
from zero to something in the next year
or two
yeah but if you're to a tongue of I Lola
why would you want to go into this
situation Greg where you're gonna be
running for your life just trade it away
you're your best offensive lineman you
don't have any weapons and you're gonna
be asked to be the savior for a bad team
for a couple of years yeah that's
exactly right but you know the other the
other thought is they they draft a
franchise quarterback and they also have
you know another first-round pick and
two second-round picks to go get
alignment or two or a pass rusher or
something else they really need you know
they I don't know how a rookie
quarterback is going to look look at it
but in my mind there's something to be
said for hey I'm going to be the save
you here I'm going to turn this
franchise around and I'm
to be a hero well my concern is because
of who they've drafted they're in this
situation so now how can I count on
those who have been drafting to then
draft better with all these draft picks
that you're getting by tanking
well that's a fair that's a fair
question you know they don't have a
great track record I think they have
made a couple of decent picks in the
past two or three years they've sort of
had an uptick in in their draft success
but yeah I mean it's it's all a
crapshoot down here it's you know it's
similar to what the Marlins are doing
really and when what Derrick Jeter's
doing down here he's asking fans to to
trust him when fans have had very little
reason to trust anything to do with the
Marlins and it's it's sort of the same
with the Dolphins right now I did wonder
this Greg and maybe this is stretching
the story that the Dolphins are just
waiting out Tom Brady we've been
thinking and saying and writing that
down here for at least five years I mean
at least five years where we're waiting
for Belichick to retire and we're
waiting for Brady to get really old and
neither neither seems to be happening
but yeah there's some truth to that
um you know there is light after Brady
you know there's some hope there alone
but you know what the Dolphins really
just need is a franchise quarterback you
see all over the NFL whether it's
Patrick mahomes deshaun Watson I mean
one great quarterback can truly turn
around a franchise and I think that's
what they're counting on I joked about
this when Josh Rosen was traded to the
Dolphins and I said you know what he
could end up in the same situation
the Dolphins had the worst record you
bring in your quarterback to a-- just
like arizona did his Josh Rosen gonna
get a fair shake here yeah I think he
will I'm astonished that they didn't
start the season with him it's really an
anomaly to be a rebuilding team and and
to start a 36 year old journeyman
you know they they should have gone with
Rosen from the outset but my
understanding is that they're probably
going to make a switch right around the
but I think they have a fifth week by
they're going to go with the veteran the
first few games I think and then and
then you'll see a
Rosa you know the imperative this season
is they need to have an idea what they
have in Josh Rosen
you know if miraculously a light bulb
goes on and all of a sudden he looks
like a really good quarterback then in
him you either have a steady starter for
next year while the well the the rookie
develops or you know you have trade bait
perhaps he develops a market for Josh
Rosen so there's a number of reasons to
really find out what you have in frozen
would you rather cover a bad team or
mediocre team a whole said that I want
one extreme or the other you know I want
the team chasing a Super Bowl or I want
the absolute dire calamity of a one and
fifteen season it's it's the mediocrity
it's all these run of seven and nine
type seasons that's listen really bored
here tears I think how fans feel but as
a journalist that's the way I feel have
a good weekend Greg tell us to godson
Dan that we said hello we'll do it thank
you Greg Greg Kody Miami Herald
columnist for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]